tema ma veniamo queste spese online e
allora tutto manca manca è 50 pacchi di
carta igienica fondamentali 50
battigelli quindi pacchetti c che
servono 50 ma ti sei scordato
nell'ultimo lockdown con cosa ti sei
pulito lì dietro ecco evitiamo mamme
prima verso il 2020
iscriviti al canale per non perdere
neanche un video mamma fritto che c'è al
39 lasci un momento importantissimo
non permetterò a quella squadra di avere
la meglio sulla nostra famiglia
alessandro abbiamo passato cose peggiori
come la malaria la peste ce la faremo
anche stavolta ce la faremo
mamma mamma tipici e disporre la
chiusura al pubblico ma va chiuderanno
tutto di nuovo dove sembra tranquilla
figlia mi consente non permetterò questo
virus di avere la meglio sulla nostra
famiglia
mettiamo la tua sete ciò quando si è
rotta la lavatrice o dovuto lavare tutta
ma ripete insieme a me ciao ma mi sarei
tornata amore mio come è andata a scuola
ho preso nove matematica e la propria
detto questa sala ci prova del maghreb
bravissimo amore ciao ma mi sono tornate
ferma lì non ti permetterò di infettare
questa casa chiudi gli occhi ma per che
cosa stai dicendo
chiudi gli occhi che vetta
ma no no no non ho capito bene dov'è che
puoi andare tu in discoteca in discoteca
a 14 anni ma sei impazzita mamma ti
prego ci vanno tutte le mie amiche togli
adesso fini subito in campo equipe ha
queste idee malsane ed aiutato le scelte
in piena crisi ormonale così dispiace
world hanno chiuso oppure le discoteche
cioè i nostri ragazzi non posso neanche
viversi la loro età andare a ballare
baciarsi in discoteca
non vedo l'ora che riaprono questi
locali non avrei mai detto e non vedo
l'ora di mandare nel discoteca mamma che
vuole le caramelle che mi ha preso mi
piacciono vitali a buonissimo tua mamma
ti inizia sempre buone le caramelle
compreso
[Musica]
se la batte le mani vero sì cioè credo
di sì no no allora credi di sì o sì
perché è diverso si è cosa è toccato
dopo si sa chi lavato le mani
l'asciugamano fare lo spiritoso con me
cosa è toccato dopo l'asciugamano
l'armadietto dove preso le caramelle
norma detto ma tu lo sai quanti microbi
ci saranno sopra quella armadietto domi
le mani subito non mi aiutate mai sempre
tutto io devo fare
lavare stirare cucinare e anche le
vostre stanze vi mettete in ordine ma
cosa credete che sia la vostra serva per
caso tanto cosa volete che cambi per me
io sono sempre stata in quarantena
sempre chiuso in questa casa a pulire
lavare stirare e cucinare con una
squadra con una serba
cosa vuoi che li facciamo questo coro la
svista
[Musica]